What was this movie in Thailand?
Uh, is my buddy as Seth green was a,
he wrote and directed a movie.
And so he asked me to do something
in it and you know, like,
cause I don't really pursue acting
like at all off kind of thing.
And I'm not saying it was a
favor or anything like that,
but at the same time it was like,
yeah, it sounds like fun. So, uh,
schoolcast it's like him, uh, he's
in a brick and Myers and it, uh,
Brenda Song, uh, me.
So do you just like do whatever you want
these days and just occasionally act
when it comes up? Yeah, if it comes up,
like, you know, if it's a cool look,
neat little gig or something like that,
like, yeah, sure. But, uh, like I said,
I don't pursue it in any
kind of like any way.
Like I don't have agents
anymore and things like that.
Is that because you're just not
interested or not interested?
I don't really like the, uh, the
pursuit of it, you know, like, yeah,
like what it takes to assess.
Exactly.
I don't like being on the circuit kind of
thing looking at. Yeah. So, uh, but yeah,
no, I um, you know, I
write a lot, I paint a lot.
Like I just kind of always have some
kind of projects. And then also, uh,
like I said, we've got the website,
a bunny ears.com kind of thing.
And what does that, that is a, it's a
comedy website. It's pretty much, uh,
like, uh, like, you know how all these
celebrities, especially like ladies,
they have those, uh, lifestyle websites.
All of them. Well, a lot of them do,
you know, look. Yeah, like Goop, you know,
just one of them. Is there other ones?
Oh yeah, yeah. No, it's okay. It's a goop
ones. The most egregious though. Yeah.
Well that's the thing,
is that, so this is,
this isn't like goop meets the onion
soup is like goop meets the onion.
Yeah, I knew all yet, but accident
it accidentally, you know? Yeah.
They're telling you to put jade balls
up your vagina. I know. Believe me,
we had an years. Yeah, we have an, we
have an article beach in a hot, hold on.
What does that just do? That
thing. Oh, annoying. Yeah.
How to have sex on the beach in a hot
tub and other things that seemed fun as a
virgin. It's Hannah, Hannah and Michael.
He's a hunter.
She's a fantastic writer.
You've got to look a little
scroll and things like,
say you have a podcast as well. Yeah,
we do a podcast also. Um, and we,
we have, we're revving up some,
uh, more like video content
and things, but uh, yeah,
so this is just a fun project.
It's got a lot of really great writers,
like comedy writers and stuff.
Yeah. It's kind of just like, oh,
like there's a good article
about a jade egg. Like, oh,
I put a jade egg up my vagina and
I catch a jade bird, you know,
like that kind of thing. You're
like, you know, and then like,
you know what to do about your bird
living in your vagina. Now look at like,
it's like, you know what I mean? We're,
we're kind of like taking the
piss out of like, you know,
some of these kind of like
lifestyley websites, you know,
it's like, um, it's like,
you know, they'll have articles
like on coop about like, oh,
the best cabernets like for like $200
or something. That, and it's like,
ours is like the best Bourbon's under $20,
but then like a turn,
like the spelling gets worse and worse,
and then it turns into a rant
about your ex girlfriend.
So like things like that, it's, it's,
it's some really good stuff. Like I said,
we have a really, really great
team of people and uh, yeah, it's,
it's kind of like I said,
taking the piss out of things.
And so you just decided to do this just
for fun? Yeah, I kind of had this idea,
it was kind of kicking
it around and so forth.
And then I felt like I kind of accumulated
enough ideas and then, uh, yeah,
then I start kind of vultron in it. Like,
just grabbing the assembling, you know,
like this, this, this, this, this project,
this giant, giant robot, you know? Yeah.
So there you go. It's, it, it, it's
a lot of fun and it's, it is funny,
like we have a look.
I said there's actually a look.
Those articles are really well written,
like we have one about, um, uh,
do you see infinity war? Uh,
the, the, the, yeah, the vendors.
Oh, okay. Yeah, because, oh, it's
fantastic. It's fantastic. But were like,
we made our own infinity gauntlet. And
what happens is like in a spoiler alert,
uh, is like, a lot of the people kind of
just vanish. Like they kind of just die.
Like,
you know,
they turn into dust in a movie and the
movie at the end when you start reading
the article, uh, um, uh,
all of a sudden just all the words
just start vanishing and like,
and then you have to go back. And again,
it's like a, even like they'll letters,
like we actually had a, um, we did
one where it was a ransom letter.
One of our writers, she, um, her father
is actually the therapist for a group,
like the extra like psychiatrist,
the official one.
So we do pass their own
therapist, you know? Yes,
but is it like a weekly advice therapist
or is it just like therapy just for
being on goop? Like I know you're
here because you're a mass,
so here just read this, read this.
It's okay. So we're here for you.
So we got pictures of him bound and
gagged and it's like dear goop, like we,
we kidnapped your therapist.
Uh,
w you can only get him back if you'd give
us your seven hot tips for, you know,
yeah. Like, uh, uh, for
facial washes for this summer.
And you know what?
They actually good on them.
They responded and they actually like
sent us over like a list of like,
here are the hot, like kind of like,
I was like, you know, good for them.
Like they had a sense of humor about
the whole thing. Look at again,
they have two, they're called
coop. Yeah. We, oh, we almost,
we thought about naming ours.
Puig uh, that's probably sue.
Yeah, I know. I was like,
yeah, like, no, no, no. So, um,
so you're basically financially
set from all those movies.
So I do okay for myself,
but do you just put that money away
and just live off the interest so much?
Pretty much, you know?
Yeah. And uh, yeah, I've,
I'm able to kind of live the life that,
you know,
like that I, that my circumstances
afforded me. I'm, I'm, like I said,
I'm very, very, very lucky. You know,
lots of weird things happen to kids all
the time, all around the world, every day,
you know, I have something to show for
it, you know, like, yeah. Like, you know,
so it's Nice I can live.
Um, it's, uh, my buddy jack,
he goes to a weird way to
describe a movie career. Yeah.
I'm pretty much weird things
happen to kids. Yeah. Man,
I got some money out of it.
Look, I'm, I'm not working like the
diamond mines. I'm not a child soldier.
You know what I mean? Like I, like I
got lucky, I came up the other end, uh,
and I have something to show for it.
And I'm very like,
I do feel blessed every
morning kind of thing.
Let's say you're happy that it
all worked out that one. Yeah.
You can go back and do it again
when you do it the same way. Uh,
knowing what I know now, I mean
probably, you know, I probably, yeah,
I probably be even more charming.
I do it just better.
Of course you would,
right? Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
Imagine if you'd just have your brain, a
little kid's body. Uh, yeah, I know. I,
I would kill it grade school. I would
so kill it. Like in school, like, oh,
psychological warfare, they wouldn't
know what's coming out of fucks.
Mr. A little brains up and nuts. Oh,
exactly. They would. That would be great.
I'm pretty sure that's what
a 30 going on 13 was. Right.
And that goes up to Jennifer
Gardner movie, you know? Yeah.
I have no idea what any Jennifer garden
wounds are. Well, you know, now you do.
Yeah. Going on 13 yeah. Like a
a brain swap one kind of. Yes.
But she like, yeah. How words
or adult brain goes into
freaky Friday.
You're looking,
so it's kind of a freaky Friday with
some time travel. I guess so. Yeah.
So you're gonna, you're gonna,
you're going to Netflix it
tonight, aren't ya? Nope.
I can tell it. I can, I can see it. I,
you've been thoroughly charmed by, uh,
Jennifer Gardner. I can tell him
interesting life you have then you,
so you just kind of do whatever
you want. Yeah. My friend Genx is,
I'm a man of leisure. That's the way he
described was like my life and lifestyle.
That's a good way to describe it.
And it's true.
And like I kind of looked at him kind of,
I'm going to spend some time just like
jumping around like Europe or something
like that. Like, you know,
and just look at like you lived
in Paris who were saying, yeah.
Lived there for a number of
years. I mean, I still have,
I still have my place there,
but uh, since like 2013,
so many that it's only in the last year
I've been kind of spending more time in
the states. Was it that brought
you to Paris? Well, the food sucks.
The wines terrible and the women are ugly,
but otherwise it's fantastic.
Yeah, no, it's okay. It
was an agreeable lifestyle.
I did a bunch of friends out there.
There was always asking me,
when are you gonna move to Paris?
And when he learned French,
any like your friends in Paris.
And I was there just kind of like,
I was just kind of jumping around
a little bit. And so, um, I,
I thought about it for a second and I
went, you know what, how's next week?
So I said, I'm going to leave my bags
here, I'm going to fly back to New York.
I'm going to going, you know, I'll, uh,
put my affairs in order. And I said,
I'll be back next week. I
said, I'll, I'll, I'll, I'm
ready to live here. I mean,
I realized that if I could pick up
and just move to France on a whim, um,
and it wouldn't affect like,
you know,
like anyone's life or it
wouldn't hurt anybody.
I think that I'd be remiss if I didn't
look, you know what I mean? Like, yeah,
like how many, how many times in
my life, I couldn't do that now,
but I could do it back then kind of
thing. So it was like, yeah, like, no,
I should just fuck it. Look, I'm, I'm
good. I'm going to live in Paris now.
And it was, it was great. It was
a lot of people who've done that.
Johnny Depp lived there for a
little while. I know Richard,
he still has a place there for a while.
No, it's, it's a special place. I mean,
what's special about it? Um, I mean
again, food and wine's fantastic. Look,
the girls are pretty like it.
It's the leisurely kind of like
lifestyle little bit like I like,
I like their eating
habits, you know, I get it,
it's like a light breakfast and kind of
gets heavier as you kind of go along in
the day. You kind of eat later, which is
kind of like, you know, like, like, oh,
you're American, you must want to
eat dinner at like eight, eight.
I look 10:00 PM 10:00 PM is looking
at, you know, kind of a, you know,
an ideal like dinner kind
of time. Um, they don't like
to work hard either. Right?
I mean, no, I mean they, I mean, they,
they work, I mean, I think, you know,
I like to take their time and everything
is like, yeah, it's like, uh, you know,
I'll set up a card game for like three 30
and three 30 means like five, you know,
again, that's just the way, like
everyone's kind of always late,
but it's no big deal. That's the thing.
It's like, I remember one time coming,
I'm like, oh gosh, like, you know,
just like, where are they kind of,
and then I realized, I'm like, wait,
what is the hurry look for real?
Like what is the hurry? It's not like I
have other plans. My plan is to hang out,
like, you know, with you guys. And so,
and all of a sudden the stress would just
kind of just melt away. I'm like, yeah,
like look, you can just be
more leisurely and stuff, uh,
about things out there and everyone's
looking at him. Like I said, it's,
it's really cool. They like Americans
out there. That's a misconception.
And if they don't like, they don't like
the loud, obnoxious Americans with the,
you know, Mickey mouse tee shirt
and the fatty. Yeah, no fanny packs.
How dare you.